you
and see how good my mouse is to me there
we go
we have liftoff here why did I start off
with d4 let's throw this age upon them
okay sneak attack age six the bishop has
to run back home let's build a center
all right let's kick this Knight to
square he doesn't want to have to go to
discover tricks let's get my pieces
develop my knight wants to be in on this
d6 square I'm gonna just run out of the
way if I'm in check right here it's
close to being big trouble I didn't like
seeing that why did I take forever with
that move okay I'm just gonna sidestep
any check oh oh I could have just Castle
22 seconds not doing so great with my
mouse that's it blame the mouse blame
that Mouse the Queen is trapped gone
just like that up a rook now alright
there's no need to Castle oh the rook is
dead time is the only issue here twelve
seconds should be plenty close to me
no clothes alright my knight is in the
corner but who cares who cares about
that
all right this is the cleanest way
cleanest way Wow back to tournament it's
been a while
oh I gave took forever all right I'm
forgetting to double the points my
opponents are beating me to doubling the
points and that's when you know it's
been a long time yes it has let's stop
my opponent from removing control over
these dark squares
I want my knight around to watch over
Eve five I want to control that square
g4 is very ambitious very weakening this
might still be played I almost did not
make that capture so a scary night here
I could take the pawn pawn be pinned
pawn push I have a check it's castle on
this side pawn push let's open things up
I think I'm the side who's better
developed let's do that I think captures
here is good I got this square now let's
kick came away pawn push is probably
good reply let's do that and then I'll
take like that my knight is not in a
great position oh they could have taken
there okay yeah they could have taken
here oh man 29 seconds now it should be
okay I'm gonna post my rook on d3 I'm at
I'm struggling here I am struggling here
that Mouse I tell you right here no
matter what even if the bishop one day
controls that square I'm still gonna go
there my opponent move you're not moving
why weren't they moving and just take
that not quite sure what that last move
is doing
there's pawn rolling
keep going do something this pawn is
pinned oh I thought for a second I lost
in time they lost on time that's how you
wanted to happen there my opponents lose
on time not me no I'm not playing with
much confidence right now I have a good
mouse but it's take it's taking some
getting used to
with my new setup okay
I could challenge that night right away
there is no Bishop g4 pin I'd definitely
want to think twice about playing Knight
f3 in that case if this pond were
already on d6 I should have maybe
considered something else taking with
the pond to watch over f4 but I think
this is this is good I could get this
advance in I don't want to allow f4 no
way I want to get here I'll take like
this I'm gonna work against this
isolated pawn let's play here I here I
take the rook let's trade why not tell
anyone what do we have here trades take
there and then here and then give a
check and just back my Bishop up on push
oh I'm winning the rook can you believe
that look at that sneaky pawns and
sneaky pawn attack right that's what the
check clean is on the scene right there
gobbled up the rook became a queen and
then this is it game over soon Oh was
almost game over for me
who knows what I'm talking about talking
about the adobe flash gambit actually
with my new setup I know how to undo the
potential issue with the adobe flash
gambit I could get I could get out of it
I don't have to disable it come on am I
getting Nona fried right here's oh man
okay twelve twelve twelve twelve twelve
I gotta go against the hat trick is this
guy won three games in a row
oh look at this go for the quick mate
you see how clever I was with that line
this guy went three games in a row you
know what happened the last time I tried
to get clever I got clobbered by Anton
squared who was there for you to see
that one twenty thousand people seen
that one at least at least after the
fact get this Bishop out of here get out
of my house actually wasn't in my house
he was on he was playing fair he was
playing fairly my night is going to do
some damage not really what a bonehead
move yeah why why is that Queen being so
annoying to me okay they're doubling my
pawns we're gonna have a queen trade
though it's exactly what I want that's
what I've been looking for all right
let's get these Queens off let's just
defend b4 oh why did I capture like that
that night was stupid I was stupid on
e2e
I give him an opportunity to exchange it
right I want to get my bishop on a long
diagonal okay King up all right King up
probably even again no matter what get
out of there this Knights too dangerous
it's night it's way too dangerous I'd
still be attacking the black the white
King do I even know who I'm playing and
what color I am Bob Bush if the knight
moves watch out on G to main to threat
oh I feel like I could take there
somehow oh man this is not working out
how I planned I don't even know if I
ever had a plan okay what am i doing I'm
going for time as usual sneak attacks
never expect that one or this one or
that move doesn't matter
there's no time back to terming 20 20 20
20
Lord Hayden is up there D Prince is
right on my tail and Nikolaus the guy
who always goes after my queen he
doesn't go after my king he goes after
my queen he goes after my king
indirectly by going after the lady lady
he goes after watch out for a sneaky
night before stuff let's get my bishop
on the long diagonal let's stop
any ideas of what let's get that Bishop
out of there I didn't even see how I was
playing until right now main X a player
who I know flies he runs like the wind
blows I could have taken this pawn I'm
gonna take him now you're not gonna get
a second chance are you know very few
second chances
oh what a wonderful place for that night
he needs to go let's take care first
okay the knight moves and then there's
potential for d4 okay all right let's do
this now I have a lot of pressure on d5
a lot of pressure and he's going down
let's take with my queen Oh
do I really want to lose my my queen
let's not lose my queen there it was
important I moved with my ear up to the
to the D file right because otherwise
there would be some issues with with
what what am I getting it keep running
pine keep running what I was getting at
is there would have been an issue when
the bishop was on f6 hitting hitting at
a1 they resigned back to tournament 40
30 30 30 hmm okay less than 20 minutes
complains Carlson ill Carlsen
okay I shall try Bishop e7 and get rid
of my darks for Bishop and actually
before I castled I should have done this
Knight maneuver I'm havin trouble
getting these guys working here these
tricky Knights take like that
okay here is the plan
get this Knight out of my house get rid
of this Knight plant my Bishop on this
square there he goes and there he will
stay he is a tough guy on e5 let's get
this going here
what is this Knight think he's up to no
good
there we go get him out of there flush
him out flush that night out of there
there we go
took care of business now my knight
wants to be on f6 and then soon g4 need
to reinforce this e5 point we're gonna
have a clean trade my knight don't be
allowed to get there now let's go in a
different route I should have been so
quick to give up my night anyhow let's
back up my knight wants to be there he's
gonna fall in love with the e5 square
next order business is what put pressure
on the weak pawns let's come over here I
lied I want to put pressure on E and
then I lied again could you make up your
mind what are you doing what are you
doing could've taken that bishop here we
go he's going here no matter what no
matter what I want to crash through on
the a file Oh missed that move oh that
was a sneaky move I didn't even realize
what it was doing I was not a
premeditated move there let's give
another check here no matter what
almost
how are we doing on the clock we're
doing okay actually we're doing okay
they're down on time back to terminate
56 42 42 I beat Carlson can you believe
it that wasn't the real Carlson though
November 9th November 9th get ready okay
this guy ate his Wheaties man look at
this guy he is flying I'm not too
thrilled about a night getting to this
square g4 I think would have been better
I think that was the first time I use
that line it's race that I talked about
Wheaties I talk about Nature Valley
granola bars though I get my night here
not quite let's get my bishop on the
light square bishop here Knight g4 King
G - here we go I found a way to organize
my pieces okay I should have probably
moved oh boy not here tricky checks not
really a bunch of bunch of what I want
to get to f5 okay I feel like I have
control baby where's my knight wanna be
a knight wants to support this advance
they're getting in there aren't they oh
boy oh boy I feel like I'm getting
checkmate I would kill me it really
would let's undermine this 32 seconds d
Prince you just slow down man need to
slow down oh boy
yeah oh I'm going after this one but oh
but oh I don't even know what that moves
mmm what does that even do I'm just
gonna I could take that with check over
here take him maybe I can't move I can't
move
oh no I can't stop that pun
oh I don't have any time and I'm down in
position oh oh oh Prince why'd you do
that to me ah man I wasn't even close I
wasn't even close on that one ah oh I
wasn't even close
I wasn't even close I gotta get that guy
back if we even get paired up the Prince
gave me a beating I know I thought I did
alright as soon as that advance came in
that's where there was a problem yeah
that's all it was
okay let's take care first and then here
my knight is pinned I wonder if I
realize that I wonder no no no if the
bishop takes I could have taken the
Queen let's back up I want my queen I
wanted my Queen here okay I have to
watch over this square piling up here
and I think I could take him now I have
enough on it if all my pieces on
so let's trade a little bit active rook
keep that rook active here we go keep
the rook active get the King working
here we go take that pun he's past 13
seconds Wow
where's my time going man oh no no I
must have very little time that I'm
starting with in these games they can't
stop my pond now seven point six is not
a lot why did I just give that up
there's an easier way to do it
Wow I need to get that pun there's no
way is there Oh games Ronnie kidding me
oh man it Queen 40 hang up hang up hang
up Oh
how much time I starting with a lot oh
okay
stay focused now needless to say stay
focused oh man I'm gonna get hammered
over here my king is running for his
life
oh okay
I could do it I could do it self pep
talk coming up it's coming up Queen
trade there we go there we go
I should have I should have moved my
queen here sooner I gotta go for quick
kills I have to be whoa my goodness oh
that's a mate threat oh this is looking
pretty good the knight has to come back
yes he does doesn't he does he see it oh
there's Knight check her Knight takes
Bishop here give a check Oh what am i
doing my knight is dead no he has this
fortune
oh wow tough day at the office
tough day at the office here let's
defend here since this Knight wants to
be able to move let's take like that my
Kings a fighter he is a fighter he's a
passed pawn
just give him get rolling here be in
check soon oh I thought that was gonna
be check here we go advance this pawn
again in throw my knight on d6 I should
have been thinking about that yesterday
there we go can i disrupt the king's
position
get that King out of there I should have
just given a check picked up the night
okay
get one Pig there another Pig
not too long off man
there was an easier way to do it oh my
goodness
they're down on time back to terminal
108 108 104 88 54 am i I'm not even on
the board you need to get on the board
you need to get at the top 10 so what
this means is I have to do crazy stuff
crazy stuff no more of this positional
garbage
no more busy positional garbage I have
to kill my opponent quickly oh boy
killer be killed quickly I want to keep
the Queens on you see how the things
change right away all of a sudden he
likes having the Queens on the board
does he my knight wants to be on c6
pressure in that pond I guess do that my
bishop would love to be on that diagonal
King cider queen side no way am I going
in that direction
no way no thanks
I could play here to put the fear in
them with that move and my queen here to
give check at that pond at least pawn
push discovered check I'm cutting off
that was well King can't go too far
probably a better move than that pick up
this pawn Knights pinned and it's stuck
there huh let's try that oh my goodness
I almost I almost forgot about my bishop
why did I oh it's a good thing I didn't
lose my bishop whoa I got a drop all the
way back
let's just play here no matter what
Wow I really got scared there I should
still be scared oh man okay
why am I going here now to give check
9.4 I'm only winning these games on time
that's all I ever have they're gonna
give a check see I just tried to move my
rook like a knight it's never working
back to tournament 71-38 110 110 102 101
oh here's a big one here's a big one
the Benoni okay okay should it shouldn't
this be pretty good we're gonna see
about that oh my goodness could I move
why is this guy so high rated and I'm
not understanding things isn't that
Queen trapped she is Knight takes here
oh she's down what are we talking about
it's a she Wow I think Knight takes e4
would still would have been in the game
no here's the Prince that's exactly what
you don't want to see I gotta come up
come in thought the Prince hired here
the prince I felt like I had a good
position against the prince am i doing
what a passive move what a passive move
Castle queenside
what am i doing get out of there get out
of there this is bad for me again right
here go ahead hit me with the fork I'll
hit your right back
how's that that your right back well my
queen can go too far
I'll get hammered on b7 okay my knight
oh my goodness this what was happening
last time right here wow what a what a
very passive move I didn't have to do
that Wow
is dangerous I get the bishop at least I
could time is even
I jumped this in there what's my queen
doing could she do something else
what a stupid piece my queen how about I
take the night let's do this first okay
over here where's the main where's that
me why am I not moving I'm in check
that's bad I'm not seeing that
I could have just taken the coin there
town none time but up at that game oh
man we're going crazy damn we were just
playing with our mice we're just playing
with our mice five minute warning if
you're wondering oh this is exactly what
I need a non mover a timely a timely non
mover yes give me those points can I get
into confetti land at least oh come on
the time has already gone by it would oh
man am i whining I am it sounds like
he's whining is anybody saying that if
you are thinking that it's true it
really is yes that took longer than it
should have
oh within striking distance 1:28 I'm
almost creeping up there looking for
third place okay I need a quick kill is
it possible is it possible not f6 it's
gonna move I'll do that no matter what
not really that was like an accelerated
night move night night g8 to f5 and one
shot everybody's favorite move to do
okay why did I do that I know I let's do
this I could do I could do that block I
have this supporter with my night oh boy
pawn push I almost I almost messed up
again oh man I hope the position doesn't
open up let's defend and castle okay
I think everything's good now I'm
feeling a lot better a lot better here
at the Queen and now kept this pawn
rolling he wants to be the star of the
show get rid of this dangerous piece the
bishop there we go let's trade my pond
is defended Queen trade not so fast
there was an easier way I know there was
I know there was I know there was oh
yeah that's exactly what I wanted to do
with my night that's exactly what I
wanted
oh are you kidding me are you kidding me
it's so dangerous over here oh my god
it's dangerous
oh I think I have to give that up okay I
have to be a mouse artist right here
they're gonna take the pun yes I don't
have any time though can I do it can I
do it can I do it run pond out there
come back oh yeah
two-minute warning two-minute warning I
gotta win and everybody else has to lose
for me to get third Jonathan cm isn't
this I have a quick win against this guy
if I'm winning Sooni he resigns
I think sneak attack sneak attack
send it up oh I think I might have
something I think I think I can I'm here
no matter what this might be quick kill
this mate where's the mate where's the
me is that me it's not me Oh get back
here
get back here he resigned 68 181 I gotta
win this one quick minute 37 can't he do
it can he do it can I just get this one
and then hopefully other people don't
win I gotta go fishing Poland
sheep all move night oh oh just move
night anywhere oh I might have something
quick I might have something quick
oh he's defending I'm on it again maybe
it could be taken where's the mane I
know it feels like that it's gotta be
here somewhere is it here
just take that pun just take that pond
please just take that take that night I
mean he's taken they took the night Oh
where's the me is it around the corner
47 seconds I shouldn't move that pond
King can't go to the corner I could take
the night with check if the Queen blocks
I could take this I could take this I'm
close I'm close I'm close 25 seconds are
they gonna resign oh it's oh I'm not
getting mated am i this game's not gonna
finish at the backup and make one make
you one making one if they take the pond
they're gonna give a check they gonna
move where's the mate where's the me oh
it's right around the corner I can feel
it oh I know I had a mate somewhere
somewhere there are a lot of them that's
not it oh they letting this game finish
they didn't they didn't blow the whistle
on it yet that's me that's me that's me
do I got it I got it I got it I got I
got it
third points oh did I get it oh lucky
dock I'll take my third place confetti
oh man they usually call that a lot
sooner I'm happy with that
Oh a huge speed bump and then a drop I
think they were close to back-to-back
Oh oh man
knocked the wind out of me it's been
that long it's been that long since I
played I'll take I'll take my little
trophy home with me
all right big games all that last game I
don't know how many mates I minced a lot
a lot
you